The average lavatory seat is much cleaner
than the average toothbrush.
Your teeth are home to 10,000 million bacteria
per square centimetre.
20% of people believe they have a food allergy,
but only 2% actually do.
The American secret service tried to spike
Hitler's carrots with female hormones to change
him into a woman.
Every human has spent about half an hour as
a single cell.
Bruce Lee was so fast that they had to slow
the film down so you could see his moves.
Cows eat only grass but have 25,000 taste
buds: two and a half times as many as humans.
The CIA reads up to 5 million tweets a day.
The average American absorbs 34 GB of information
a day, though half of it is obtained from
playing video games.
If all the asteroids in the Solar System were
lumped together, they'd be smaller than the
Moon.
Because there is no weather on the Moon, the
footprints of the 12 men who walked on it
are still there.
Google earns $20 billion a year from advertising,
more than the primetime revenues of CBS, NBC,
ABC and FOX combined.
Angel Falls, in Venezuela, is 17 times higher
than Niagara.
Venus rotates so slowly on its axis that its
day is longer than its year
The entire Internet weighs about the same
as one large strawberry.
Barley has twice as many genes as people.
More than 50% of koalas have chlamydia.
Some parts of Antarctica have had no rain
or snow for 2 million years.
Melbourne used to be called Batmania.